foreign
[Music]
it's a glave and no he doesn't
run around like a kid and you're not a
kid anymore you're a man ow you know I
think I turned out okay right oh you
live with your mom all right she lives
with me okay but I pay the mortgage
you run away from people who love you
nothing is as important as family do you
know what it's like how people
constantly ask you about your brother
I Googled myself yesterday
it was bad
you don't exactly lead a quiet life
no I try to do nice things yeah they
still think I'm like a joke
we're in comedy you've got to be able to
walk away from anything in your life in
30 seconds flat that's why I got nothing
tying me down
I'm not a kid oh yeah
[Music]
thank you